pardon my language but I am miffed say I
love movies all kinds of movies movies
where Bruce Willis punches someone
movies where Tom Cruise punches someone
movies where Bruce Willis punches Tom
Cruise I love every kind of moving but
when it comes to new releases just like
my neighbor's quinceanera I want to be
invited this past weekend I was left out
it seems like the entire world went to
see the new Black Panther movie but I
felt like you feel my pain I feel it but
see I felt like I couldn't go
specifically because there were no
tickets and the only explanation is that
I was being systematically excluded by
some anti white internet overlord named
Fandango every time I asked him for a
ticket he said there were no tickets
remaining fishy look I'm not making this
about race they are it's right in the
title
Black Panther I mean we made eleven
different spider-man movies in the last
six months and we didn't call a single
one of them white spider-man
oh I get it I get it
I can't understand I get that Black
Panther is a historic groundbreaking
moment for the black community with all
black leads and all black creative team
and an afro centric vision that
celebrates different facets of the black
experience but what about me know am I
supposed to identify with stuff like
love betrayal or good versus evil if
they're not acted out by people that
specifically look exactly like me
that's that's my Pixar never makes
anyone feel anything
enough with the toys and the rats and
the robots give me more stories about
men with tall hair even though I wasn't
going to see Black Panther I didn't want
to miss a chance to pass judgment so I
said citizen journalist Aaron Jackson
and Josh sharp to see the film and
report on just how bad I assume it is
Jordan unfortunately we cannot do that
because as everyone knows Black Panther
is great right because it's all about
Trump right the far right beacons of
truth over at Breitbart said it best in
their review the movies hero is trump
the villain is black lives matter I know
what you're thinking duh but just let me
explain
Black Panther is a glorious tale of
nationalism and closed borders inspired
by one mr. president Trump herself yeah
it's set in the fictional African
country of Wakanda which is trumpian in
every way and any other themes that
might exist to the contrary frankly
don't work for me so I choose to ignore
them right
and we're not alone lots of people in
the far-right world have already begun
to claim Black Panther as their own
Chuck play the tape that's marked Paul
Joseph Watson for what candor is
homogeneous what candor is isolationist
what candor is willing to exploit its
natural resources what candor is
protected by walls with candor doesn't
allow immigration where candor is based
around national self-interest
that's literally everything you say
Trump is bad for doing see the dream to
make America great again is alive and
well in what candor or as we like to
call it maganda yeah the Margit themes
are all there if you just squint hard
enough they mined this magic metal
vibranium which is basically cold so
many jobs coming back to maganda it's
got the biggest buildings very Trump and
a bunch of fierce women who will take a
magic sword to the face for the men they
work for I see you Kellyanne
what is the lightful surprise to find
that this movie masquerading as some
sort of SJW Fantasia wet dream is
actually an indictment of anyone who
wants to disrespect our flag and export
our precious vibranium Wow I'm I totally
missed that I guess I was too busy
moderating my subreddit negative reviews
a black panther by white people who
haven't seen it that's um that's a very
specific sub right yeah we're one of
sixteen Wow
Jordan Black Panther was so Trumpy at
least the first half yeah we spent the
last half just tweeting spoilers yeah
but I'm sure we didn't miss anything
because if there's one thing I know
about movies it's that the characters
are the same at the beginning as they
are at the end and they never change or
grow just like real people ultimately
Black Panther is our movie we claimed it
at first we felt scared and left out but
then we saw a few select things that we
liked and we made them ours just like we
did with rock and roll and most
continents Wow hello
although now that the word is out that
the movies so pro-trump liberals will
probably stop seeing it oh my god yeah I
hate people that have to make everything
about themselves I'm the one who hates
that okay yeah I just sharp it every
Jackson everyone the fight continued
[Music]